I feel with her for-profit institutions
I just got my Mac Time magazine and they
have an article in here and she even
says here she said now I simply concede
the point they are right we do expect
things in return they she and her family
have put millions and billions of
dollars into their points of view and it
just it scares me it scares me that our
country has to come to for-profit
charter schools online schools i system
is better than that thanks for calling
Alice mr. Chavous well there is that's
not what she said it's not really true
most charter schools are not-for-profit
but the real question and issue I think
we should be discussing is whether or
not schools work for kids and whether or
not parents have quality options you
know right now there are million kids on
waiting list for charter schools there
are hundreds of thousands of families
that are looking for great options and
look there are some great traditional
public schools but one thing that we
have seen when you have robust school
choice options be their scholarship
scholarships or charter schools or
online educational offerings it improves
the traditional public schools and and I
appreciate the caller and I want to
thank you for teaching our kids but as
you know if you've taught them a
traditional public school system there
are far too many schools and far too
many teachers that are not working for
kids and and we can't afford to continue
this debt the downward slide that we're
seeing in so many of our schools so and
one other thing I think that a lot of
the hype around Betsy and her family and
the money that they may spend to to
promote educational choice these folks
have real compassion I mean I think her
husband and her started an aviation
charter school in Grand Rapids for kids
who want to learn about flying and being
able to maneuver around
the airport industry and has had
tremendous success so I think that
context is really important
Washington Post a little bit more than a
week ago wrote about charter schools
connecting them to a Michigan wanted to
get your reaction to what they wrote the
Post writes that for choice advocates on
the Left Michigan is a prime example of
how not to promote school choice there
is no limit on the number of charter
schools there are dozens of entities
with legal power to approve new charters
with varying levels of oversight and
there are too many poor performing
charters they argue there is also no
central source of information about
charter school performance or enrollment
so parents often face a confusing maze
of options I think you know the charter
school movement like all educational
offering entities in Katie's in the katy
trail space can be improved but one
thing Betsy's advocated for is is
greater accountability and look I think
that bad charter schools should close in
DC one of the reasons why we've had
success in the Charter movement that I
helped promote is we've closed bad
charter schools but you know what's
interesting Paul we can't close some of
those poor performing traditional public
schools right now we have nearly 1,500
dropout factories these are traditional
public schools where we know that most
of the kids are going to drop out
they've been bad for years people in
these various jurisdictions who try to
reform them change them but no one talks
about replacing them or no one talks
about shutting them down I think if
we're going to put accountability in
place that really works for parents and
we're talking about shutting down bad
charter or choice schools that don't
work we need to consider doing the thing
the same thing but you know when people
talk about closing traditional public
schools it's real difficult I think the
better course of action is to expand the
choice offerings so that parents know
that they have options beyond that
traditional school that may or may not
be working I think in America in
education we did think more expansively
as opposed to being constrictive in our
thinking that's what the rest of the
world is doing and frankly that's why
we're falling behind because we're not
doing that we want to be myopic and
narrow
find it and how we view K through 12
education we need to broaden that
approach more of your calls coming in
for Kevin Chavis on education school
choice in the u.s. just a couple of
facts and figures we can point out to
you there are 25 states plus Washington
DC that have enacted school choice
programs more than 1.9 billion and
dedicated funding is available for
school voucher and scholarship credit
tax programs and nearly 400,000 students
nationwide are enrolled in private
school choice programs that from the
Federation for children we hear from
David now from Madison Heights Michigan
independent caller good morning David hi
thank you very much for taking my call
as as we're speaking I'm getting my
boots on Kevin you're laying it on real
thick Betsy DeVos has been nothing but a
failure in our public education in
Michigan you know it and I know it she's
a bad choice for any kind of education
they're just a couple of billionaire's
David what David what are you pointing
to specifically in Michigan can you
point out an example or two yeah they're
taking or the charter schools are a
private school and they're trying to get
them oh they're a public school no they
aren't they're a private school and they
fail each and every one of them she has
destroyed the public education in
Michigan that's the bottom line
so my boots are on Kevin I wish you
would tell the viewers the real truth
about Michigan schools he has destroyed
the public education in Michigan let's
get a response from David in Michigan
wow that's a lot to put on one person
that one person destroyed public
education I you know Betsy didn't create
the environment in which 80 percent of
the boys were dropping out of school in
Detroit Public Schools she didn't create
an environment in which we have allowed
for our neglect in our urban and rural
public schools to bleed over into our
economy there are strong feelings on
this and we have this sort of nostalgic
and sentimental view of public education
the red brick schoolhouse the
day of school going to the prom there's
this real healthy American attachment to
what public education means and I know
Betsy feels the way I do we don't want
to destroy that memory we want to build
on it and many of the great schools that
are part of that sentimentality we all
hold they're no longer great and but
they can be and there's this misnomer
out there that which we want to replace
public schools or privatize public
education that's not the case what we
want to do and studies have shown this
Paul where you have increase and
broad-based school choice options the
school district gets better
let me quickly give you an example about
DC when we started our charter school
movement back in the late 90s I helped
push a chair the educational me on the
City Council we also were trying to push
reform at DC Public Schools that didn't
work
I gave DC Public Schools 300 million new
dollars over a three-year period they
had 10,000 kids leave the system so they
got 300 million new dollars to educate
10,000 fewer kids and the outputs went
down by the same token because we cut
out the bureaucracy through the Charter
movement they started to do very well
that's when I became a true believer
that that choice does matter later we
did our scholarship program and in that
scholarship program where you had you
known over the last 10 years 6,000 kids
go to private schools and they're all
doing well ninety percent graduation
rate 90 percent College going rate and
they come from schools for most of
school kids are failing
so that robust and broad-based choice
those choice options led to DC Public
Schools getting better
I mean kaya henderson who just left his
Chancellor she will tell you that
because of the competition because she
was able to incentivize her principals
by saying look at what they're doing
over there with these options it
destroyed that one-size-fits-all
paradigm that we see in most cities and
as a result DC Public Schools now has
had increased enrollment the last couple
of years so this
this is an effort to to deal with the
short term in the long term the short
term is the need to really help parents
who feel trapped because the school in
their neighborhood may not work the long
term is it provides incentives for the
local school district do better so I
think that the people who should look at
where this is taking place and use as an
example let's hear from Herbie now in
Moss Point Mississippi
Herbie thanks for waiting around the
Democrats line yes good morning I think
this is a source of parents in the book
so you can place the blame it's like
privatizing prisons it's more expensive
than then you can't hold them
accountable for what they do to the
individuals inside the prison if you
want to do anything spend the same
amount of money called housing their
prisoner and sending their kids to
school and I think that would be more we
can hold the government more responsible
than we can hold but you say charter
schools are private company and I'm
sticking with the government thanks
Herbie Kevin Chavis it's now passing
them both
you mentioned the prison situation yeah
what we're trying to do is stop that
school to Prison Pipeline you know when
I was in elected official in DC and I
read our local jail I was astonished to
find out that over ninety percent of our
inmates were high school dropouts even
today according the National Bureau of
research eighty-two percent of our
national prison population high school
dropouts eighty two percent and many of
them come from our cities our rural
communities the only way to stop that is
to make sure that we not wait on the
school traditional school district to
right-size itself that could take years
we've had reforms and reformation
efforts in these jurisdictions for the
last twenty twenty-five years I know in
DC before I got there they had had all
these reform efforts and and parents
were coming in saying what am I gonna do
about my kid who has to go to the local
school
it's not about passing it but what it is
doing is we've got to take care of
parents and kids needs today and I'm
proud of the fact that with the school
choice offerings we've been able to
develop in some of these jurisdictions
we've got now broken that tide of the
school
to Prison Pipeline this put a
stranglehold on so many of our
communities we're seeing it here in DC
and we see it in other places outside of
his support for charter schools what do
you know about president-elect Trump's a
broader platform on education and what
do you think of it well you know that's
a great question I think is to be
determined I think that he's talked
about school choice something that I
embrace and look I did not support
Donald Trump for presidency I was very
concerned about his racial intolerance
and in some of the some of the rhetoric
I do think that Betsy will help a lot
because I think she's going to help the
president-elect reach out across the
aisle and I think she's going to engage
local leaders I think she's going to be
promoting innovation and creativity I
think that's going to be something
that's big and incentivized that I think
online learning and personalized
instruction that's where the world is
headed I think you're going to see a
growth in those areas other than that I
think is to be determined I I do and I
do expect and I'm glad to see frankly
that school choice would be front and
center your name was out there for a
while as potential education secretary
but based on what you just said about
your initial concern about mr. Trump can
you see yourself working directly with
him in the education area well I see
myself working directly with Betsy DeVos
and and and I want to support our
country I was so proud of President
Obama I was on President Obama's
Education Policy Committee when he ran
the first time in 2008 and I think he
did a lot to move the ball forward he
supported charter schools he didn't
support private school scholarships
which I'm disappointed and he didn't
support our DC Opportunity Scholarship
Program but I think that he set a tone
for change that was was needed and I'm
proud of the fact that he immediately
after the election said we have to all
support this new president that's our
democracy no I didn't support Donald
Trump for president but I'm proud of the
fact that you know as Americans we need
to rally around him you know people have
said to me when my name was circulated
as a possible education secretary they
said well you shouldn't even be
associated with him because of who he is
I said each and every day every 42
seconds a child drops out of school
that's 6,000 kids a day my life's work
is centered around the
this notion that we need to stop those
dropout numbers and for me I feel a
sense of duty as an American to work
with whoever is the president whoever is
the education secretary and I think
Betsy's gonna be a great one to make
sure that we in you know that amazingly
bad statistic of us allowing kids to
drop out and their future be taken from
them before they get a chance to move
forward let's hear from Anthony now in
Northampton Pennsylvania independent
caller for Kevin Chavis good morning
Anthony good morning gentlemen thank you
for having me no understanding mr. wall
is a dedicated Christian Calvinist do we
the American people have good reason to
expect that she maintains a healthy
separation of prison state and keeps God
out of our public education system thank
you
I think that's a great question because
there's been a lot written about whether
Betsy would impose her Christian values
you know I've worked with her closely
for the last 12 13 years and not once as
she talked to me about you know
Christian values being imposed on public
education what she talks to me about
more than anything is how we can empower
parents and empowering parents is really
key Paul when I say empowering parents
I'm talking about that that our parents
know what works for their kids
educationally and that we as the
providers of education services we
provide a whole range of a menu of
options for them to pick from so that it
works for their kids if you have more
than one child you know that they're
different and so this notion that she
would try to impose her will on the
country I don't think that is is going
to happen at all I do think though
you're gonna see her and see and hear
her talk more about putting power in the
hands of parents and as I said before
giving them options that work for their
kids back to Donald Trump and perhaps
Betsy DeVos shavar Jeffries had
something
to say in the post as well recently he's
president of Democrats for education
reform and writes that based on the
positions he has taken president elect
Trump's administration will undoubtedly
hecha way of the progress we've made
toward creating a more equitable public
education system under President Obama
and irreparably damage our children's
futures here we actually well you know I
founded the group Democrats for
education reform I've talked to shebar
about this look you know what I think is
the has been the biggest barrier to
educating each and every American child
over the last 30 years politics the
toxic nature of politics in America has
been an athame to to teaching and
learning and and I think that
unfortunately and you see that we can
see this with that state music's even
hear that from some of the callers
people put party identification ahead of
what's best for kids I think that we
need to rise above the politics of the
day and and do what's best for our kids
as I tell folks when I give speeches of
there's no Republican or democratic way
to teach a kid how to read write or
count and yet if you listen to the Union
if you listen to people will promote
certain partisan issues on both sides
the aisles they say this is the
Republican education plan this is a
democratic education plan what I would
like to see happen what I'm going to
Betsy to do is let's just embrace this
idea of building a national obsession
around learning and less inspire our
kids to want to learn as opposed to
trying to tell them they need to learn
less less let's get beyond the politics
of the day or the partisanship that you
know because my candidate loss I can't
work with the other side
especially when the I think the biggest
threat to our American democracy is not
some outside force coming into our
country and killing us our biggest
threat is the threat from within when
you have 82% of our prison population
dropouts and you have more and more kids
graduating they're not ready for school
so I think that if we can build some
national consensus if the Trump
administration can do that
reach out across the aisle find common
ground and and and and make education
work for all I think that should that
should help us rise above the politics
back to phones Helen Takoma Park
Maryland independent caller for Kevin
Chavis thank you for waiting Helen they
love this school that they want to go
there they will let them go to that
school which is part of it that children
are selling behind because it select
some children to other school and other
areas which is not good for us and then
the other thing I wanted to I said they
wasn't talking is he said when they
party is the politics because they say
if your budget fairy you will support
the other ones where were they when
Republicans stood up and said we are not
going to agree with anything automatic
nobody no one fight about that which
it's wrong
thank you thanks for calling mr. Chavous
well you know I think that the way
quality options can work for parents is
one to make sure that parents are
educated consumers and I think that you
know a lot of times when I talk about
school choice and parent empowerment
people often come to me well the
problems not this kid not just the kids
the problems not just exclusive problems
with the parents and you have generation
on top of generation of parents who
don't know how to exercise school choice
I mean I've heard people who say that
parents don't have that wherewithal the
exercise school choice I think that what
we have seen when we've created school
choice programs to work and I'd like to
see Betsy put more money aside for this
is that we we train the trainers and we
make sure parents can be educated
consumers when we did the DC Opportunity
Scholarship Program we have parent
workshops so that they know how to
evaluate schools they know how to
evaluate teachers and with our most you
know challenged communities there there
doesn't need to be a more of an
information curve so that they can
exercise the power of choice because
choice is a major responsibility
and you know schools can be intimidating
particularly if you can't read or have
them in to educate yourself so I think
that you know that there's a lot we can
do to make sure that choice works for
all and particularly that if we're going
to empower parents that they have the
skillset necessary to exercise that
empowerment so you've been pushing for
parental involvement and more of it for
a long time how do you accomplish that
these days the way society is structured
busy parents a lot of families separated
how do you do that Paul that's a great
question and you know I think that let's
again take out the discussion of just
choice in and of ourselves I think
school districts as a whole could do a
better job of parent engagement you know
even when in the reform community when
Michelle Rhee took over DC Public
Schools and had I think some great
reform ideas you know one of the things
they put at the bottom within at the
bottom of the list is parent engagement
and and I think as opposed that should
be at the front of the list and I also
think that the problem we have in
American public education when we talk
about engaged in parents there's always
top-down I think needs to be bottom-up
so you know one thing we did in New
Orleans when we had our scholarship bill
passed we went to public house and we've
worked with the resident council we
found the leaders and community that
trusted voices the influencers we train
the trainers and we made it peer to peer
now even you know I mean I can walk in
these communities and and you know with
my suit and I can talk and they'll drown
out and they'll drown me out is they
just did I can't they can't connect but
you know the best way to engage parents
is through people that they listen to
people they trust in their communities
and I think that as a whole and I think
again to something Betsy should consider
we need to figure out the best way to
build grassroot parent engagement armies
to help train parents to be able to
exercise their responsibilities to pick
the right school for their children to
be advocates for their parents and when
that happens is magic you know one quick
thing went Harlem children zone under
Geoffrey Canada they did an amazing job
of getting parents engaged so much so
that you have so many parents going back
to get their GED I think that is
supposed to education being in this
either-or box easier for public schools
or your for private schools here for
charter schools you know either you're
Republican or Democrat you know we
shouldn't have an education approach to
education where people have to pick
sides let's empower parents because once
we're inspire people to want to learn
even parents they'll go back and get
their GED and it's a beautiful thing to
see on to Fort Walton Beach Florida
Democratic caller its Ellis good morning
to you Ellis thank you right colors to
but my question more in the mechanics of
operating these private schools there
are particularly here in Florida there
are people here in Florida that have not
that were not educated here in Florida
so when you come to the tax base and
you're talking about private schools as
opposed to public schools I'm thinking
that there's probably going to be some
lawsuits by saying that we shouldn't pay
cause pay taxes because of major portion
of my taxes my County taxes was for
public schools this year so if you're
going to convert them all the private
schools why should I have to pay taxes
to support private schools when I had
nobody educated in the state of Florida
so I think you look going down a
slippery slope that could in turn defund
public schools so you somebody's time to
look at the mechanics of it and I hope
they thought about this all the way
through all right okay let's get a
reaction from mr. Chavis yeah well you
know one of the things that people need
to be clear about we're not talking
about privatizing public education the
lion's share most
our kids will be educated in the
traditional public setting but when you
mentioned Florida you know one thing
that I think that the Trump
administration in under Betsy's
leadership is apartment of education
secretary may consider is looking at
what Florida's done with his Florida tax
credit scholarship program now and this
gets to the heart of the caller's
question under that program we have
nearly a hundred thousand kids who are
able to attend private schools and based
on corporate donations and which
corporations receive a tax credit for it
it's a wildly successful program and you
know two things happen one is you're
able to get low income kids because
they're all means-tested so they're the
working class free reduced lunch you get
these kids who are in challenged schools
and they go to private schools and it's
really based on corporate dollars and
and the program is wildly successful the
kids are doing well you have African
American ministerial alliances big
supporters over at Martin Luther human
third supports it and then the other
thing that happens which a lot of people
don't realize is those schools where the
kids have come from those kids are doing
better so you've taken kids from some of
the most challenged schools and put them
in environment the worse for them you've
exercised parent choice and you this the
kids that are left behind those kids are
doing better we've had a Northwestern
study on that professors figlio and Hart
did the study and it's is it none of it
is on the public dime so I think that
that's a model that we're going to be
looking at hopefully the Betsi will look
at around the country because I
understand a lot of people feel some
real angst about public dollars spending
all this money for public dollars in a
notion that will privatize and that's
not what we want to do couple tweets for
you one viewer wants to know mr. Chavez
is it not evident that poor public
schools are found in urban centers how
about changing the way public schools
are funded that's a great question and
you know the deep dark dirty secret is
that
you know most of our public schools are
sliding somewhat that's why we see the
challenge you know in terms of our
comparisons around around the world with
other industrialized nations around the
world and and it is true that a lot of
our urban schools are fading but another
deep dark dirty secret is our rural
schools aren't quite as well and I think
that that the the the Genesis for that
is sort of this one-size-fits-all thing
where we're used to doing the same way
the same time you know the same approach
and that was born out of the Industrial
Revolution the 93 school day was put in
place because of the agricultural model
so kids could work in the field before
they went to school and have time before
it got dark and even summers off so they
could harvest so you know this has been
virtually unchanged for 150 years and
and I think that's contributed since
then we've had a couple world wars
technology revolution and we're still
doing it the same way algebra in the
ninth grade you know it hadn't changed
and and I think that the dynamism
associate of innovation is what we want
to get to and you know in terms of
funding I think the funding formulas are
really tough in many states and they do
need to be addressed but while we're
waiting to fix that cuz state
legislatures look at funding formulas
that's a long process almost like
traditional school reforms a long
process this is where choice can help
incentivize it and and help help kids
today and also help reform the system
here's an interesting question via
Twitter and a really broad question
Barclay wants to know what recompense
will there be for those whom for whom
education has already failed them and
their futures are imperiled that's a
great question I think one answer is you
know it's in the vocational education
space and and I think that's why you see
you know President Obama and even
president elect Trump has talked a
little bit about vocational education I
think that when people develop skills
even if the system has failed them then
they're able to to help right-size their
lives and and I think that we need to do
a better job in terms of
broad-based school choice offerings is
is creating more of these vocational
options and we can do that Susan through
some creative ways in the Charter
movement let's get one last call and
it's Luis from Colorado Springs
Republican caller good morning
oh good morning gentlemen and thank you
for c-span course I just wanted to thank
mr. Chavous for what he's doing you're
doing a good job and the right thing and
this charter school thing is is the way
to go and I think just for example here
in Colorado if somebody were to move
here and put their schools and their
children excuse me and a dimmer of
public schools they would see exactly
why this charter schools are needed so
the parents can send their kids where
they want to to better their education
because it is all about the kids so
thank you again mr. Chavous and keep up
the good work god bless you final
thoughts on education policy and where
this new administration that's coming
and is going to be headed well first of
all I thank the caller uh uh but look
I'm hopeful I think as as our current
president said it's time for us to come
together what I'd like to see happen is
that we not create a Republican
education agenda or a democratic
education agenda but we reach across the
aisle and we build a national obsession
around learning we can instill personal
and national pride around education I
think Betsy DeVos can help us get there
I'm going to do all I can not just to
support her but support our country so
that we can get rid of those statistics
in which so many of our children are
lost in the system doesn't serve them
and I think that's that's the
centerpiece of our future Kevin Davis is
a former DC city councilman founder and
board chair emeritus of Democrats for
education reform and is currently
executive counsel of the American
Federation for Children Federation for
Children org is the website thanks for
coming on this morning thank you very
much Paul appreciating we will take
another short timeout and then talk with
Professor Carol Anderson of Emory
University she has written a book titled
white rage the unspoken truth of our
racial divide we'll go through that book
and we'll take more of your
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this week on c-span tonight at 8:00
former Vice President Dick Cheney and
former Defense Secretary Leon Panetta on
the future of the Defense Department
under president elect Donald Trump I
think the the challenges are very great
and I think we have unfortunately over
the course of the last many years done
serious damage to our capabilities to be
able to meet those threats we're living
in that period where there are a lot of
flash points and a new administration is
going to have to look at at that kind of
world
and obviously define policy that we we
need in order to deal with that but then
develop the defense policy to confront
that kind of world
Thursday at 8:00 p.m. Eastern a look at
the career of Vice president-elect Mike
Pence and amidst the shifting sands of
contemporary culture in law we have
stood without apology for the sanctity
of life the importance of marriage and
the freedom of religion on Friday night
beginning at 8:00 farewell speeches and
tributes to several outgoing senators
including Harry Reid Barbara Boxer Kelly
Ayotte
and Dan coats this week in primetime on
c-span
Sunday January 1st in depth will feature
a live discussion on the presidency of
Barack Obama we're taking your phone
calls tweets emails and Facebook
questions during the program our panel
includes April Ryan White House
correspondent for American urban radio
networks and author of the presidency in
black and white my up-close view of
three presidents and race in America
Princeton University professor Eddie
clown author of democracy in black how
race still enslaves the American soul
and Pulitzer prize-winning journalist
and associate editor of The Washington
Post David marinus author of Barack
Obama the story watch in-depth live from
noon to 3:00 p.m. Eastern on Sunday on
book TV on c-span 2
Washington journal continues our guest
now is Carol Anderson a professor in the
African American Studies department at
Emory University that's in Atlanta
correct and professor Anderson is author
of this book it's titled white rage the
unspoken truth of our racial divide and
the the book in part stems from an op-ed
you wrote for The Washington Post a
couple of years ago at the time of
Ferguson and the headline to that piece
if we'll show it to our audience says
this Ferguson isn't about black rage
against cops it's white rage against
progress so take those terms to start us
off black rage and white rage and put
those in context in your view and so it
was doing Ferguson when the the protests
are happening there's a fire in the
streets and all of that and all of the
pundits regardless of what I get logical
stripe the venue a CNN c-span met in the
MSNBC Fox they were all talking about
black rage about black people being so
angry this anti-cop violence and blowing
up things and the question was why are
they burning up where they live why are
they burning up where they live and as
everybody was talking about black rage I
was shaking my head going no this is
white rage I have lived in Missouri for
thirteen years and I saw the way that
public policies worked to actually
undermine african-americans access to
their citizenship rights and that was
that white rage it's cool it's
calculated it comes out of the courts
out of legislatures it's not the thing
that you see in the streets but it is
lethal
I just went back a couple of years but
the book is a history book of sorts and
it goes back well more than a hundred
years tell us more about the history in
this area and so what I began to do was
to chart that when African Americans
made significant progress access to
their citizenship rights and that you
saw then a wave of policies roll up
to undermine those citizenship rights so
I start with right after the Civil War
with reconstruction and so this is this
moment where African Americans move from
being like legal property to actually be
in human beings to them being citizens
and that was such a seismic shift that
you saw this movement come up from the
white house from state legislatures from
the Supreme Court to gut the 13th 14th
and 15th amendments again I track it
through the great migration where
African Americans are leaving the South
in droves looking for good schools good
jobs and the right not to be lynched and
and instead they faced a number of
barriers I then track it to the brown
decision of 1954 and 55 then civil
rights and then the election of Barack
Obama phone numbers on the bottom of the
screen for our guest professor Carol
Anderson will take your calls in a
couple of minutes from Republicans and
Democrats and independents a little bit
from the book white rage you write is
not about visible violence but rather it
works its way through the courts the
legislators in a range of government
bureaucracies it wreaks havoc subtly
almost imperceptibly white rage doesn't
have to wear sheets or burn crosses or
take to the streets working the halls of
power it can achieve its end far more
effectively far more destructively the
trigger for white rage inevitably is
black advancement it is not the mere
presence of black people that is the
problem rather it is blackness with
ambition with Drive with purpose with
aspirations and with demands for full
and equal citizenship it is blackness
that refuses to accept subjugation to
give up tell us more yes and so what one
of the things that we have is a
narrative in the society that if only
black people would write if only they
would value schools if only they would
work hard if only they would
da-da-da-da-da-da fill in the blank but
when you look back historically
african-americans have actually done
that but for aspiring the response has
been a wave of policies to undermine
that I'll just take a most more recent
one so you saw in the 2008 election and
in the 2012 election african-americans
came out in record numbers to vote in
the 2012 election actually
african-americans participation rate in
the vote exceeded that of whites what
you have immediately following that now
we should be saying we value democracy
we want people to vote we want people to
participate in this democracy to feel
like they have a stake in it but what
you saw immediately after that very high
participation rate was first the Supreme
Court's Shelby County v holder decision
that we can severely the Voting Rights
Act of 1965 and then you have a wave of
voter suppression laws that were
designed as the Fourth Circuit said
about North Carolina that targeted
african-americans with nearly surgical
precision to find a way to stop them
from voting before we get to calls one
more question about present day what are
you expecting during a Donald Trump
administration I'm expecting that white
rage will be in its full glory that it
will through the courts through the
legislature will seek to enact and embed
a whole series of laws and policies that
that undermine african-americans access
to citizenship rights the progress that
we had made during the Obama
administration such as with sentencing
reform I'm expecting that to go by the
wayside with understanding that the war
on drugs and mass incarceration is not
the way to go I'm expecting in fact a
double down on so-called law and order
to the phones for professor Carol
Anderson author of white rage Herman is
calling first from synchros Louisiana
Democratic caller hi Herman to me to ask
this question because I get there can
you be a citizen of two countries there
is a watch that I'm I'm a citizen of the
United States of America
I'm labeled as african-american here in
the United States so what I'm so quick
to what I'm getting at is why are we
label african-american and the white
race is just the white America we all
ascended from someplace
yeah Herman why don't you start by
answering your own question then we'll
hear from the professor yeah why don't
you answer your own question first and
then we'll hear from the professor okay
go back then can you be a citizen of two
cultures
okay he's asking I was hoping he'd
elaborate a little bit but let's hear
from you
yeah and so first to understand that
well Africa is a continent and the the
the the description of African Americans
is part of a long-standing move for
black people in the United States to
define themselves to go from the inward
to colored to Negro and then Negro with
a capital in to african-american and
that is part of a way to to that
definition of self because again when
you realize that that for many blacks in
the United States
slavery is the legacy that legacy of
property and we have been fighting
against that legacy of property since
1619 and then with 1865 again it has
been that battle against the the
definition that black people are less
than recent polls and surveys in fact
show that today in 2016 black people are
seen as being less than Americans that
battle will not be erased if black
people's just simply say hey we're just
Americans and I'll take the example of
Brazil
in Brazil they don't identify by race
but what you see is that black
brazilians in fact have greater poverty
lower education greater criminalization
and what that does then is that when
they organize to fight against that the
government says but we don't have
statistics by race so that really can't
be happening and so part of what you're
seeing here is this push for identity
and the push to have the data to make
sure that it's very clear what these
kinds of systemic policies the systemic
inequality has meant for black people in
the United States that's here from Paul
who is in Indianapolis independent
caller for a professor Anderson hi Paul
good morning morning senator Anderson
I've been looking at this problem since
I retired a few years ago and I've come
to the conclusion that the real root of
the problem that we all have to face is
not so much in slavery but in the rise
of scientific racism starting with the
predecessors of Darwin this whole idea
that was proclaimed really hemily in the
late 19th century that there was a
ranking of human beings that the English
were on top and then there were the rest
of the Europeans and then there were the
Asians and there were the Africans is
this whole idea which gained such was
received science and all the great
universities I mean you look at Woodrow
Wilson who was probably one of the worst
racists in American history was a
college professor who taught this kind
of thing the misuse of Darwin's teaching
seems to me to be at the heart of this
problem it's gotten embedded in our
universities it's gotten embedded in our
thinking until we root out the whole
idea of race which science is now
proving to be illogical and without
basis we cannot really going to get
their slavery doesn't seem to explain it
because after all slavery would practice
more widely in Africa than it was in new
world there were far more
who owned slaves in the African states
that sold slaves there were in the
United States you know it's probably
true that your far back ancestors are
more likely to own slaves and my far
back ancestors were so I just wanted and
you ever have you looked at it from the
point of view of the misuse of what I
would call social Darwinism or
scientific race thank you Paul there's a
lot there professor why don't you go
ahead and unpack that I sure will
first it's not just the science slavery
part of understanding slavers to
understand the way that for instance
religion worked and the power of
religion so that you have this thing
being ordained by God and you know once
you slap God on top of something that is
absolutely horrific it gives power and
meaning to it in ways and so that whole
curse of ham thing to explain why
Africans could be enslaved and I also
want to deal with the the way that
slavery was done in the United States
was so fundamentally different than the
way that it was done in African kingdoms
slavery in the United States was
multi-generational it was chattel
slavery that that the the status of the
enslaved carry through to the child
carry through to that that the child's
child carry through through the child's
child's child that is so fundamentally
different if we try to erase the role of
slavery what we erase then is that by
the time of the Civil War eighty percent
of the United States G&P was attached to
slavery we erased the economic power of
the United States that was built on the
backs of the enslaved and then we erase
then the kind of religious fervor in the
religious ration now that comes behind
it and then you merge that with the
science now it hasn't
then as you say still embedded in the
Academy in fact what the Academy has
done has been to talk about how race is
a social construct but what is also
clear is that the policies and the
systems that have come up because of
that construct are real and the way that
people face those constructs so that we
know there's differential in the way
that policing happens we know there's
differential in the way that employment
happens and that construct in fact
affects life chances in life quality
more of what you write in white rage
once it became clear that the voter
turnout rate of blacks had nearly
equaled that of whites as penta hair of
the progressive advancement project it
noted conservatives were looking at it
and saying we've got to clamp things
down they'd always try to suppress the
black vote but it was then that they
came up with the new schemes those
efforts hit the anger a determination
behind a legitimate sounding noteworthy
concern protecting the integrity of the
ballot box from voter fraud yes because
white rage really probably epitope if
election really swaddles itself in the
flag particularly after the civil rights
movement and so protecting the integrity
of the ballot box sounds just I mean who
could be against this but what you see
are these schemes for instance where
I'll take North Carolina again that
where they said the GOP said let's let's
get the racial data on voting and looked
at okay how do black people vote we see
that they use early voting instead of
just most of them coming out on that
Tuesday Election Day many of them vote
early so we're going to constrict the
number of early voting days that should
cut down the number of black voters we
see that there are certain types of IDs
that they don't have those are the IDS
that we will require and then we will
make it more difficult to gain those IDs
I mean so this is that kind of surgical
targeting of african-americans for any
backup for doing exactly what they're
supposed to be doing
that's that's the way white rage works
adding to that is this piece in the
nation that we found the headline says
the gops attack on Voting Rights was the
most under covered story of 2016 they
write that there were 25 debates during
the presidential primaries an election
and not a single question about the
attack on voting rights even though this
was the first presidential election in
50 years without the full protections of
the Voting Rights Act they go on to
write that this was the biggest under
coverage scandal of the 2016 campaign
what why under covered and and I'm still
trying to figure that out because this
is huge I did a piece where after the
brexit vote there were several here who
were writing we saw the rise of like
nationalists in the brexit vote but that
won't happen here because we have this
firewall we have this demographic
firewall of blacks and Latinos I wrote
that that firewall is is breached to hit
us under attack and we're seeing it
where in Wisconsin you had GOP
legislators who were absolutely giddy is
the it's the quote giddy about slicing
and dicing the the vote so that
particularly blacks in Milwaukee would
have a much harder time voting they were
they were pleased about that we see it
in Texas where the n-double-a-cp
and the Legal Defense Fund both found in
their joint report that up to one point
six million blacks and Latinos would not
have access to this certain type of ID
that the state was now requiring so why
this is under underreported not taken
into account I have to say that maybe
it's because what it did was to target
blacks and Latinos and and and you
didn't want to insert race into the the
the election debate but it needed to be
there because when we are denying
American citizens the right to vote
we are trampling on democracy and we
need to understand that Stone Mountain
Georgia on the line Democrat Latoya for
buzzer Carol Anderson good morning
Latoya good morning good morning I'm
miss Anderson I'm morning I hate I hear
you and me being a black woman and as
long as they've been knowing about all
the IDS and the voter suppression and
everything while we wait to the last
minute to try to fight it in court
we always fight behind the 8-ball this
don't make no sense and when we try to
say that they try to put all these are
blocks in our way we knew it before the
election started so you know sometimes
you know we can't be
we always kappa the fact we got to be
proactive and clean up and take away as
he choose the truth yeah they did all
that don't you said they in Georgia they
doing some it in every red space that
you have a Republican leader
they have suppressed the boat in some
kind of way now in Flint mission in
Flint Michigan man where they dealing
with the water problems I did it I did
analysis baby you gotta vote and it's so
hurtful that now see the thing is is
that we is almost like yeah they had an
enslaved and if it wasn't for laws they
will see a harbor in slavery and that's
the sad part they know they're in their
stores because they want to stay honest
in this for us because they have to
everything they do is because they have
to because he you think they always
think they write about everything I have
never seen a group of people that think
that they was God gift to this world and
not that we it's like everybody make up
the world and it's one race that's
coming down on everybody and we just
standing around watching them do it
donut truck is accident but Republicans
what they got planned for him it's on
purpose check it out watch it and watch
how this trail lead back to us the
senate leader on this email trash that
they've been doing we say we all been
duped
we've been do but that's alright because
he in the last we gotta be proactive and
not always subtracting
thank you for calling professor yes and
and I would say that part of is that the
moment that the Supreme Court gutted the
Voting Rights Act
you saw mobilization across the nation
part of what you don't see is that it
doesn't get this it doesn't get big
media attention so you you know we hear
about moral Mondays but only every now
and then there were a series of lawsuits
early on by the ACLU by the
n-double-a-cp by the n-double-a-cp Legal
Defense Fund
you saw activism it wasn't like people
were waiting until 2016 to file these
suits they started early so I I will
push back on the sense that black people
were waiting until the last minute no
they weren't part of what you're also
seeing is that you had a group called
vote writers that was also out there
trying to help people get those IDs and
running to all kinds of crazy barriers
up in Wisconsin a man had to to go from
Wisconsin to another state to go get his
original birth certificate then they
said no because one name one letter was
wrong on that birth certificate so I had
to go do something I mean we saw all
kinds of shenanigans that were happening
this was no last-minute thing done from
Vallejo California a democratic caller
thanks for getting up early to talk to
us hi Don mrs. Anderson I'm quite sure
you are a educator and you know
everything like that but now I'm
wondering have you ever you know decided
to go to the Bible to the Word of God in
order to find out what our history is
about because black people in America
are cursed and the curse is from God and
our oppresses is the white man which is
oppressor of the world because the Bible
says the earth is given into the
the wicked Joe nine and sixteen okay and
so therefore everything is done by him
because he's covered the faces of the
real judges which is Jesus Christ which
was a black man and they gave us this
white Jesus that we have now and we're
following their ways and ways of life as
opposed to the way that we were which
were the Jews of antiquity we are the
real Jews of America then we're not
Americans we're not Africans we're not
none of that we are jus Deitz from
Israel we are the real Jews you need to
listen to the Israelites everyone in
America all you blacks Hispanics and
Native Americans you need to turn to the
Israelites and listen to their program
at listen to what they're trying to say
because everything they say comes from
the Bible comments from Dawn there let's
get a reaction from our guest and I
would say as you know as I mentioned
earlier that the Bible has actually been
used to provide cover for the
subjugation of black people in the
United States I think that is an
absolute miss reading and misuse of the
Bible and one of the things that we saw
in the civil rights movement in fact
with that you had ministers black
ministers who had been preaching from
the it is bad down here but it's
supposed to be bad down here for black
people that's what the Bible says and so
what you have to do is you have to take
it and then you will get yours in the
by-and-by in the hereafter and then
another wave led by Reverend Vernon
John's and then the Reverend dr. Martin
Luther King came up and they started
reading from another side of the Bible
and so and that's one of the things we
have to understand about the Bible is
that it is open to interpretation and it
is also open to the the uses for those
who have very pernicious very pernicious
intent and so we really have to think
about what what that Bible is saying in
terms of basic humanity
basic decency that's where we need to be
really reading and not about issues of
subjugation and oppression to st. Paul's
North Carolina independent caller named
Al good morning to you al everybody
there's several things one I think that
in every race and every religion 2 or 3
percent of people or evil and we don't
fight a war against the evil people also
black lace matters started under
President Obama and if you look it seems
like the left is always on the side of
evil you have a young african-american
who was arrested and charged with
transporting drugs across state lines
and then went before the judge and told
the judge he didn't know he was
transporting drugs he borrowed the car
from a friend and didn't know there were
structures in the car and the judge told
him that he was the one driving the car
across state lines with drugs in it an
ignorance of the law was not a defense
and sentenced him to 20 years in prison
but if the same judge was to prosecute
someone like Hillary Clinton he would
sell her that she sat in racine
classified emails download them onto a
private server gave it to her attorneys
and then Adam delete classified emails
but the witch is not being prosecuted 8
years with President Obama still a rich
white or not being prosecuted also an
African American and Hispanic has
arrested the African Americans they both
go through due process the African
American is found guilty he's sentenced
to 10 years in prison we have enough
money to incarcerate them but we don't
have enough money
the